Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is a caller
who thinks he knows what Obama gate is. You
might remember this whole thing. Obama gate
that started being pushed by the Trumpists during
the Trump campaign during the Trump presidency.
This caller believes he knows what it is. Listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. I was hoping I could trade
you on what Obama day to. Yeah. Obama gate. Obama
gate is just the simple fact that a black man
got elected president of the United States. Only
thing that was controversial to these hateful,
racist people. And that alone is Obama's
gate. The fact that a black man got elected
president of the United States. So if you wonder
whether, as I look at it, that's what it was.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, there's one opinion.
Remember, Obama gate was brought up by Donald
Trump. And during a press conference, a reporter
raised his hand and said, What is Obama gate? And
Trump said, you're a journalist. You know what it
is. And of course, nobody to this day knows what
Obama gate actually is. We have a great bonus
show for you today. We are going to talk about
what is happening in Afghanistan now under Taliban
rule. This is not about Joe Biden did the right or
wrong thing. I believe he did the right thing.
Trump was going to do the same thing and getting
out of Afghanistan, we knew that it would not be
great under the Taliban. But at a certain point,
it has to end. And we will talk about what life
is like under the Taliban in Afghanistan. It's
not good. As a preview for today's bonus
show story. We're also going to go back
to this shooting where actor Alec Baldwin killed
someone. It's it's crazy to say it and it just
kind of the story went away. But Alec Baldwin shot
dead someone on the on the set of the film Rust.
And we've heard very little about it for a period
of time. We're going to talk about where the
investigation stands today and also maybe in a
sign of sort of conceding a number of important
races. The Republican National Committee is
dramatically reducing their ad spend in a
number of Senate battleground races. Why are they
doing it? And what does this mean for the upcoming
midterm elections? All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show, which you can sign up for
at join Packman dot com. I also want to remind you
that another great member benefit is occasionally
we will do member only viewer town halls
and we are doing one of those on Wednesday,
August 31st at 6 p.m. Eastern. This will be an
event that will be streamed for everyone to watch,
but only our website members will be invited to
participate in this particular town hall. We'll
do other general town halls in the future.
This particular one is a members only town
hall and you can sign up at join Packman
dot com to get access and to participate.
So we'll see you on the bonus show today. Sign
up and otherwise we'll be back here tomorrow.